[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thank you for joining
us if you're here for Nestor carbon now
you found the right place if I messed up
his name he'll kill me
he's awesome this guy is so awesome I I
met him at a con he couldn't be nicer
he's not only a great actor but he's a
great guy he's a director he's a he does
it all
but what a sweet man and I've always
been a fan I've seen a lot of things
he's been in and uh I'm a big fan so
listen to some stuff that we're going to
talk about and then we'll get into that
but uh if you really enjoy the podcast
it helps us so much if you write a
review subscribe tell other people you
really liked it and to give it give it a
chance
um at inside you podcast on Instagram
and Facebook at inside youpod on the
Tweeter and uh look it's the SAG after
strike and what that means for the
podcast is a lot of these all these as
of now are pre-recorded so we're okay
and we put a little disclaimer but
um you know the podcast will continue
it's continuing we've got permission
other podcasts are doing it we just have
to find uh you know you know what's the
word um
listen to the guidelines and uh
yeah
follow the following follow follow me
follow me follow me follow me that was
Snoop Dogg who said that
but um but yeah we've got a lot in the
cancer nothing to worry about we've got
at least another couple of months before
I need new guests so no need to worry
but if you want to join patreon to
support the podcast and keep it afloat
like my patrons have done
patreon.com inside of you very important
um top tiers get there's a lot of perks
and we're adding perks but the top tiers
get a box sent for me every couple
months in a personalized note
um they get uh YouTube lives where we
they ask questions they get to ask [__]
talking questions on that are now I
think going to become a patron exclusive
um and so many more things so join
patreon support the podcast become a top
tier Patron if you want or just give it
any way you can
um I will be at a bunch of cons in
September so go on my link Tree on
Instagram the link link tree and you can
see where I'll be I'll be all over so
come see me I'd love to see you trying
to get a big patreon Gathering probably
in DC
um even if it's for an hour or so just
to see all you guys I would love that
um
but yeah
that's what I'll say
that is what you said that's what I said
yeah inside of your online store tons of
cool merch uh new zip up jackets that
were a bestseller inside of you Ryan has
one I have one I love them they're the
most comfortable things you'll ever wear
I promise you
um they're on sale along with a bunch of
other cool cool stuff and
um I'm on the Cameo as well and uh the
band sunspin sunspin.com to get merch
zooms all that stuff you could also get
zooms with me and Tom Welling on the um
Taco podcast uh website neat uh okay
I guess we should get into it yeah yeah
I think it's time we get into it do you
have anything else you want to share no
you were in the same shirt last week I
was was I yeah yeah
[Laughter]
we are homely people oh God no this
one's a fun one uh I'm excited for this
one and by the way how are you guys
doing uh you know I I don't ask all the
time
but I do care Ryan cares uh Ryan are you
you feel like your mental health is in a
better place it's in a place it's been
of constantly being worked on it's
constantly being worked on and I think
that's good you're still with better
help yep yeah some days are better than
others yeah absolutely but it's
important to keep doing it
um you know you're gonna have those
weeks you're gonna have good weeks where
you don't think you need therapy and
then people tend to not go to therapy oh
Save A Buck and I don't need it because
I feel good yeah but it's it's a it's a
check-in it's like working on your body
it's like physical you know what I mean
you gotta you gotta keep that up man
um
so I hope you're all doing well and
taking care of yourself because you're
the most important things if you're
trying to take care of a million things
and you're not taking care of yourself
you're not going to be good to anybody
including yourself so I'm just hoping
you're uh looking out for yourself all
right without further Ado let's get into
it let's get inside of Nestor carbonel
he's got a wonderful career and you're
gonna love this guy it's my
[Music]
it's my side of you you with Michael
Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
I want to make it like a sort of a uh a
retreat in a way come over you put your
feet up you relax we karaoke we watch
movies we hang out in the back we have
drinks we play games you know it's kind
of like I'm a big kid and I just want
you know my grandma's house was always
open to everybody but my parents it
wasn't so I never was allowed to have
friends over it's interesting so like
what was everything was meticulous and
very easy you know what's really weird
it just it makes a lot of sense so my
mother if you walked in the house
like perfect
um
carpet you know how the everything's a
vacuum yeah it's perfect everything
looked perfect right but if you ever
opened a drawer or a cabinet or
everything would fall apart I mean it
was just in shambles a mess but was it
disorganized or just like broken just
disorganized in the in the drawer you
realize oh my God this is broken and
just things stuffed in there like
everything on the outside
and it you know it's it's funny we're
recording right
it's funny because
a lot of times I look at myself and I go
okay and my therapist said this they're
like you need to keep everything around
you in order you need to be you know I
guess meticulous is the word you used
but um if everything around you is not
in order you will not be in order and so
it's it seems to me like
there's so much going on in my mind I'm
there's a lot of chaos there's a lot you
know I grew up a lot of dysfunction and
stuff that I talk about but uh I just
this is so funny I'm just thinking about
this for the first time but
my mother everything on the outside
appeared so it was almost like her
personality she would pretend that I've
got everything going on and she she
didn't she like inside she was like
dealing with a lot of stuff and anxiety
and you know just so I wonder how many
people do that like how many people sort
of like hey you walk in their house is
really clean and but they're a mess well
let's start with Instagram
I mean you know yeah you know that that
is sort of an extension of what people
of essentially what you're saying your
mom would would do is you paint a
picture for the outside world that isn't
entirely accurate you know right and and
it's you know I think that a lot of us
do that you know I mean a lot of us are
no I'm certainly guilty of that and then
you have to check yourself you have to
be like
dude let's get real you know there's uh
it's not it's not what I'm portraying
all the time right and as as I know you
know because you're you're such a I mean
I I just you know from when I met you
you know in Cincinnati you when you talk
to people you want to get at the truth
you wanna and and you're open about how
you truthfully are as well which disarms
people in a great way and allows them to
open up and that is how you connect with
people ultimately when I meet people for
the first time you know usually
everything's surface you know it's like
you don't have time to like you know
it's usually hey how you doing no one's
gonna be like oh not great you're like
oh [__] what happened you know usually
it's just like hey nice to me oh yeah
great uh you know when it's like well
that's a quick one yes yeah of course
but like I when I met you
however brief when we talked a bit a
little bit and we were on the plane
together yeah but I and I told Ryan I go
this guy is like the most down to earth
just I mean it just feels like you're
just a regular good guy who
I mean on the outside at least [__]
together no but thank you but no I'm I'm
like everyone else you know you know
full of a thousand contradictions you
know uh a mess many days sometimes less
so than others you know when you say a
mess what does that mean I mean you know
like anything you know I I mean I I
struggle with
just uh you know any any the typical
fears that people struggle with you know
day to day the voices in your head that
they're saying that the criticisms and
all that stuff and a lot of it is like
okay let's manage those you know and you
know you pick up things along the way
and you you lean on things that you've
learned but by and large you know for
for me you know as an actor you know
Ryan you're an actor as well right yeah
yeah sure I've been on YouTube yes yes
I've been on the YouTube or are you
saying like in life like yeah sure we're
all putting on a face that kind of thing
well there's that too there's the double
entender but you know but you know in
this business you know whether it's on
YouTube in any medium you know it's it's
tough and it's tough not to hear the the
the the the voices of criticism in your
head and how do you navigate those
things and how do you deal with anxiety
and how do you deal with
you know a career that is like it's so
unpredictable you don't know there's no
consistency necessarily unless you get
on a show and you hope that this level
of consistency there and even then that
goes away that goes away it's ephemeral
everything's ephemeral there's no
question you know
um what's crazy is I look at your uh by
the way how would you say your name like
the real way you say it uh Nestor
carbonel no in English I mean like if
you were in Cuba or you were somewhere
like how would you say it uh my my
parents would say Nestor caronel Nestor
cabinet that was an accent on the E if
you want to throw that out so Nestor
Garden but you know I mean it's nestro
carbonyl or many other things that
people have called me it's what's crazy
is
when I first got to see you on TV I
think the first time I saw you've been
in tons of stuff and I know I'm I've
seen you but the role that really
probably everybody was like whoa was
lost right that was the big one one of
the big ones I mean suddenly Susan you
were on tons of stuff but like no the
most impact for sure I mean I yeah that
that opened up the world right certainly
for TV for me in a different way but I
had I'm sure a lot of other people
didn't realize that you know you had
this I I didn't know you spoke like that
you could speak Spanish like that you
could speak you know that you you where
your roots are if you just look at you
you don't think that you're like I'm
sure maybe is it Italian is it is it
Jewish or is it yeah yeah and then you
start speaking on my effortless him how
did he learn all that well he actually
speaks the language
you know what I mean
um no well thank you it's a cool thing
thank you but I I mean I I I was born to
Cuban Exiles who exiled cube in 1960 my
parents both you know exiled they met
actually was that hard to do by the way
to leave Cuba for them it was brutal I
bet they they I mean they had to they
had to what what they were facing at the
time you know I mean but our family's
history there is is is pretty it's very
tragic you know certainly within the
after the Castro's Revolution I had an
uncle who
was executed by Castro another one was
in prison for 17 years you know uh was
this your dad's brother my dad's uh
cousin because his dad's cousin
absolutely and my father participated in
the Bay of Pigs uncle in prison for 17
years and tortured for rejecting
indoctrination and demarxism so we have
a long history of you know wow so they
fled you know hoping to return or fight
for you know freedom of Cuba and you
know and they didn't you know they never
returned uh because you know the Bay of
Pigs Fiasco and so so yeah it was brutal
for them to leave my mom was 15 you know
didn't speak of much English at all so
uh and they moved here yeah they my mom
landed in New York you know in Miami
first in different homes like they were
just sent to like if there's an uncle
living there at the time or had a place
temper with the end the idea that they
were going to go back that there was no
way that the U.S would allow this you
know Marxist stronghold you know 90
miles off the shore right and and they
never went back my mom didn't see her
mom my grandmother for nine years
so because her mother stayed in Cuba and
sent the kids off to relatives in Miami
so so it was really tough for them so I
grew up with those stories you know and
was it hard for them in the United
States because people oh you're Cuban
over we're at war with Cuba where
there's this was there any of that like
sort of like uh Pearl harbor-ish you
know Japanese Americans and dealing with
all that [__] I know that there were
there were there was tough transitions
you know in the beginning in Florida you
know I mean there's a language barrier
there's you're right anytime a new
immigrant group or Exile group comes in
there's always like you know what do we
do with this you know and and
understandably you just you don't know
and to a certain extent who that you
know why they're here what's going on so
I could see you know why I could say I
could I could understand why that that
would happen so yeah they encountered
some of that uh and yet they also
encountered a country that opened them
up we're open to them with open arms and
quickly embraced it as their own and
thank God for this country you know I
mean and thank God that this country was
here for them because is they would
never have had those opportunities
anywhere else yeah were you privy I mean
to seeing the strength of your parents
was it pretty true was pretty apparent
how strong they were and how hard
working they were and how you know was
that apparent to you it's a great
question man and I'd love to hear your
end of this too I don't know if you do I
do yeah well I do because I I'm I well
no no I wanna I consider myself
incredibly lucky because they didn't
they came with nothing they came with
what they had in their pockets they they
came from families that were prominent
Cuba politically and and you know and
they've done well over the years
um they lost it all it was all taken uh
by Castro so they had money and they
were doing really well in Cuba yeah like
yes they were yes and they they and they
were fighting for democracy they were
fighting against the incumbent dictator
who was Batista right as much as they
were against Castro they're trying to
restore democracy my so you know so they
were yeah they were they were but they
lost all like every Cuban Exile they
came with what they had in their pockets
so I grew up with those stories with
stories of them having nothing uh my the
only thing my father did have was it was
a great education and that's knows yeah
that is no small thing
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
sometimes in life we're faced with tough
choices and the path forward isn't
always clear whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online so it's convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
betterhelp.com slash inside this message
is sponsored by discover did you know
you could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
so you know they they might they both
work so hard incredibly hard my mom was
a tour guide at Rockefeller Center my
dad you know had a law degree he was he
was nine years older than her so he went
to Harvard right he went to Harvard he
got his Masters there so he and your
sister went to Harvard he got she got a
master's degree you went to Harvard
that's so annoying I know it's not
annoying it's like wow I mean it almost
seems like my the real reason I'm sort
of saying that is because what I'm
thinking is how hard on you would it
have been to see your your parents and I
want you to keep talking about what you
were talking about but seeing them how
hard they were in their education and
you're dabbing a lawyer but also
was it a stress on you that I have to
follow in My Father's Footsteps of the
education and I have to work really hard
and I have to was it ingrained in you
you know it's another great question
dude you're full of great questions get
ready for the bad ones get ready for the
bad ones no because it yeah I was very
lucky in the sense that my father struck
this balance I'm a mother as well where
it was not about the result and it was
always about the effort I remember like
I had we lived we had the privilege of
living in London three different times
because my dad worked for Pepsi
International we were moved all over the
world right and I remember we were I was
there it was third or fourth grade and I
was in the American School in London at
one point and he you know he came back
my grades came in and he's like okay we
need to talk about this I go and he goes
I that this the B minus the C plus here
I don't care about that he goes it's
this section here on effort where you
have a c that's the one that bothers me
and I was like and it sank and I go what
he goes I don't care about the result I
want you to work hard whatever you do
and since that moment it's interesting
how that stayed with me I was like okay
I was working I'll just work hard I work
hard and and it and it did stay with me
so I never had that they never imposed
on me you have to go to this school or
that school and it was never about that
but it was under stood that that we were
expected to work our butts off you know
and not take these opportunities for
granted that's
awesome what about you well this is uh
the podcast about you no no no give and
take people look
um I didn't come from a very um yeah you
know I wouldn't say normal family I you
know definitely dysfunctional as I
talked about Ad nauseam but you know in
terms of Education
um
I I've always had attention deficit
disorder I've always I mean I know
sometimes it feels like an excuse to
people like everybody's got attention if
you get to know me like Ryan or if you
get to know you know it's like squirrel
it's like it's really hard for me to
focus and being a child uh you know I
wasn't drugged up which I'm grateful for
but at the same time
um there wasn't a lot of patience in my
household no one sat me down and said
hey you know let's just take our time
take a deep breath
let's learn this and let's you know and
no it was I had there was no it was just
like I'm not getting good grades why I
don't know get better grades there
wasn't any of that so for me it was just
growing up feeling really stupid like I
felt I wasn't intelligent I I can't do
things and my grades are bad why can't I
do even simple things and no it's like
it's almost like no one just really paid
enough attention or any attention so I
felt like I was colorblind yet I was
going to art class and getting D's and
F's and no one was figuring it out and
I'm like why are you failing the color
wheel primary colors secondary colors I
was like it's all I don't know what any
of this means I so it just felt like I
had a learning uh deficiency and
so I look back and I definitely am able
now to think hey you didn't have the
things you needed as a child you didn't
have the patience you didn't have the
understanding and the love and all the
things that a child in his developmental
stages needs so I'm aware of that and it
comforts me knowing that you know that
was unfortunate and it wasn't my fault
and I wasn't dumb I just didn't have the
right circumstances I think my parents
did the best they could you know my dad
worked never missed a day at work worked
from 6 a.m to 6 p.m came home had dinner
you know you know hopefully it was in a
good mood and then I left and I was so
we didn't have really the best
relationship it wasn't really affection
or anything like that so it's different
it's different
um
um but I do I am what's the word I
respect
that my father really worked hard and
provided for his family but I think
um some men or women think that just
providing a loan
you're a great parent if I put a roof
over your head right and I give you the
things you need that means I'm a good
parent and that's not true it's more
about the affection the love the
understanding the patience all the
things that go into parenting and I just
think think he knew that they did know
that and my mother I think was the
center of attention she wasn't ready
she shouldn't have had children you know
what I mean she was she was out for
herself she was more interested in her
life than she was ours and that's just
that's just reality I don't I don't hate
her for it it's just like that's that so
it's a different mentality that's why I
was like Hey listen night and day and
look listen I'm a parent now and right
knows do you make mistakes uh do I ever
man and um constantly and I think what's
the old adage that you try and screw up
your kids uh half as much as you thought
you were screwing together so uh yeah I
don't know if I'm doing that how I'm
doing on that regard are you patient
with them you know I try I try this you
know there are things I think I do
better than other things and what's your
strengths
what's my strength I I try to lead by
example I try I don't always right um I
try to uh own up to my mistakes and let
them know that you know I just messed up
you realize that and I'm owning it
things like that if they ask you a
question if they say Dad did you ever
drink would you go yes I did yeah and
that's an interesting question though it
depends at what age of course you know
Dad are you a drunk yeah
eight years old no I'm not no I'm not
you know but but uh no that's a really
layered and interesting question because
I think there is a time when you can
tell them that stuff sure you don't like
anything but no I think in terms of if
the uh you know trying to pass on things
that I find helpful uh you know
particularly as we were talking about
things that are challenging in this
industry just like you know how to deal
with mental health you know how to deal
with you know the voices of criticism
how to deal with anxiety you know things
that I think I find helpful uh things
that I find you know and you know how
the the old adage success leaves
footsteps is seeing how other people
have done it you know and and being open
to the world and saying look you know
you take from this example in this
example being malleable right just
valuable make your bed you know at least
if you had a bad day at least you know
you made your bed yeah you know it's
things like that or it's or it's
gratitude I know I I listen to your
interview with Robert Patrick it was
amazing and yeah it was beautiful and he
spoke about that about how he gets up in
the morning and he prays and he gets on
it puts a pillow on it and he Nails on
it and he and he thanks God for waking
up that morning do you do that you know
I don't do that specifically but you
know not not too long ago we've been
implementing this notion of like three
things that you're grateful for at the
you know where we have a meal that's
awesome and it's and it it does affect
your day you know if you start the day
or at least or even in the middle of the
day if you do that it puts everything in
perspective it's just you know and you
know so so that the someone else the
other day we were having dinner and
someone I'm sure this is something a lot
of people know but I didn't know about
this but he said instead of saying I
gotta do this you say I get to do this
I got it Ryan think about that when you
wake everyone I gotta go do this damn
podcast hey I get to do this podcast
it's kind of fun
it it it's incredible I need to do that
too not not the easiest you got to do
that no you get to do that yeah I get to
do that no I guess you got to do you
have to make that choice you get to make
that choice to use get instead of have
to and it's amazing how a shift in a
word you know the way you ascribe a word
you know how how it changes the meaning
or you're so it's things like that that
I hope is apparent that I'm able to
impart on them you know that that I
think are more helpful than not when did
you decide like uh I'm sure you told the
story but you know you got a degree in
English right did you get your Masters
in Harvard no I just it was just it was
just afterwards but were you doing
theater at Harvard no here's the thing
at at school in Harvard at the time is
that there was not much of a an acting
program at all I didn't know what I was
I wanted to do all I knew was I you know
I applied to all these schools you know
and then I was like okay I guess I'll go
there you know and I had no clue I had
no idea I didn't know that I had no I'd
never acted up you know at that point I
hadn't even been in a school play I know
interested in it and then and I I
thought I'd be a lawyer you know I
thought I'd go into some kind of
business and then there was one elective
at the time at Harvard that was um
taught by this man named David wheeler
who was incredible acting coach I think
he coached Pacino for years and wow you
know he was he was well known and I
didn't know anything about him at the
time but I you know later found out oh
he's like a big he's like a big deal
yeah and he uh introduced me to this
book you know the class uh Meisner on
acting sacrificed on Act and it was
until I read that book you know you know
Francis back that I realized wow this is
something I want to explore and there
was nothing else no other electives at
Harvard at the time there was one other
one at the American Repertory Theater
that you could take at Shakespeare thing
that was it other than that with their
people were doing uh plays in the
basements of the houses so what'd you do
so I did plays in the basements yeah you
did that and then eventually I was like
I gotta study this technique you know
and so I had to wait until I graduated
which is a bummer but you know but I
couldn't wait and I I did I was like I
gotta finish for my parents say because
I was like there's nothing here is going
to be particularly applicable to what I
want to do but I can't do that to my
parents now and did they know you were
doing this plays in the basement
they didn't see you ever no because yeah
who's gonna go to the basement it's not
like I was selling out the art you know
so so no so I I dropped the bomb on them
you know and I don't know how that went
over with you you know because I think
I'd heard you say that yeah I just
remember we were in Denny's after I did
a play I think it was pretty to a kiss
or something and I just looked at my dad
I was like
I'm gonna be an actor and he goes eat
your steak
and that was that and hold on was this
you went to college right you went to
Indiana I went to Western Kentucky
University in Kentucky all of it yeah my
life is just a lot of
Lucky in the right place at the right
time making the right decisions and some
of it being very prepared luckily it was
just a lot of
you know just things that just happened
that I I could have gone in so many
different directions not many it would
have been like I would have been a DJ at
a roller rink or a um working at a
go-kart shop or nothing nothing wrong
with wrestleman's grocery second
groceries or working at Sunoco
um gas station and you know it was one
of those things where all of a sudden uh
you know when this guy that lived down
the street goes hey and he was popular
hey you wanna hey I go to Western
Kentucky man we'll be roommates I'm
going I go okay and I just and I got in
it was easy to get in and then I went
there and that's why I went to college
and did you did you apply to other
schools or that was just the one because
that was it that was that was amazing
that was it but it was an easy school to
get into and by the way I'm glad it was
that school because I learned so much
because you know
College really isn't all about or the
majority isn't about you know great
grades and and it's really about how
learning how to be social learning how
meeting people that are on the same
wavelength being creative
um growing up there's so many other
variables it's just not I gotta study
and get to do this to get to this job of
course there's that but you know I think
it's experience and experience not only
with with with you know work but
experience with who you are and growing
up and becoming the individual that you
know you're destined to be you're
absolutely right I mean it's the first
time for most people that they're out of
the house and that they're they're
commuting they're living with people you
know roughly the same age and they're
kind of on their own ish you know so
there is that you're right all the
interpersonal stuff all that social
stuff is sort of the first time you're
exposed you're kind of thrown into the
deep end in that regard so that is yeah
and but you're right I mean for those
who are studying for you and I who went
for more of a bachelor arts degree it's
less about okay what grade you're going
to get unless you need to go into
Academia and some some level but yeah
for the people who are trying to you
know who are going to become doctors
obviously lawyers you know they got to
put the work in you got Engineers for me
there's no way around that wasn't on the
table no we're neither it wasn't
familiar I was not a matching Wiz or
anything like that so I was never 12
times 11.
132. I think that's right
yeah because uh then you add 12 144 is
12 times 12. so I'm obviously done hey
you know but what what uh
did you have like I'm obviously doing
these plays in the basement and you're
getting some it was there one person in
particular that you remember going he
looks at you and says or she and says
hey you've got something there I think
you should do that was there because we
all need that person this is such a
great
um
yeah it's a really good it's a great
point because I've never thought of it
like that you had to have someone along
the way even if you started to make it
you were wherever that projector are you
you know I don't know that there's any
one individual who said this like dude
you gotta you have to pursue this
you know I was terrible in the beginning
I was awful you know it was I was like
whatever I don't you know I was in my
head I was like what is nervous nervous
all of the above I wanted it you know
once I knew I loved it I wanted it too
much all those pitfalls you know I fell
into and it it just was a gradual sort
of progression of I thought of like okay
you know I'll find this I'm gonna find
it you know so there was one guy at
Harvard who did have his own company and
he used students his name was Eric Engel
and he did do a few Productions that
were not in the basement and he was
pretty great and I remember I remember
he had an impact on me because I I just
I don't know that that was one one guy
who who definitely did
um so yeah I think maybe maybe it was
Eric Engel it might have been Eric Engel
look at that you haven't thought about
that name for a while it's been a long
time since I thought about Eric yeah
um what is the first gig you got that
you're getting paid you're on TV it's
something like uh do you remember that
moment when you found out you got it for
the first time I want to hear about
yours too all right okay go ahead all
right we will trade okay but my this one
is I find it I thought it was quite epic
because I was a kid you know I already
knew what I wanted so in the Summers my
parents live in Greenwich Connecticut so
not a long commute to New York City I
was able to get a waitering job I met
waiters who had commercial agents I got
with the commercial agent started going
out for commercials in the summer and so
I went up for all these you know
National commercials for you know just
an All-American kid I just wasn't I
wasn't getting the All-American roles
you know I wasn't even getting close
callbacks and a buddy of mine who would
book a bunch of these he's like dude you
know you gotta work the the Latin angle
got to work that Latino I go and I go
yeah you know they're going to send me
to some you know Spanish-speaking ones
he goes yeah dude Andy because whatever
you do
you know you've seen those things
they're really like sort of exuberant
they're just really just because you
just many just go for it I go really
goes yeah Manny just go for it so I went
up for the zest commercial and I'm just
fully clean you're not fully clean until
your zest fully clean okay so try doing
that in Spanish and so can you do it yes
so that was the copy and it was like I
remembered like going in there getting
this copy and there's like 400 dudes
that signed up before me I'm like oh my
God and then I I had my friend in my
head saying no you got it you gotta I
had like this awful like cliched moment
in in the mirror outside you know in in
the in the uh in the bathroom of the
outside the casting office now okay need
to go for this and you're gonna go for
it you're gonna go for it and I did and
I went for it and I got in there and I
go
and the cash director goes great give me
more so I like I just kept amping it up
that's amazing so went home I booked the
job I was I was like 19. it was I was
going to get my sag card I was over the
moon I was like jumping up and down I
got the clothes you know I get to this
set and I remember meeting the director
and he goes to me hey do you remember
what you did in the audition I go yeah
he goes don't do that
why I was like what he goes don't do
that I go oh okay we're not going to do
that obviously they just hired me for my
look or my you know I don't know but it
was in Spanish it wasn't Spanish I just
had to do it so you just did it very
calm down is that either I brought it
down a few notches but it was to me I I
hit the lottery you know and it ran for
a while it ran ran for enough it didn't
pay much the the Spanish who cares man
it was exactly it was like it's more
than I was waking it making as a waiter
and it was my sad card and I was 19 and
that was beautiful I want to hear yours
you know I think I got this part
on it was called it was a CBS show Matt
Waters educating Matt Waters with Montel
Williams and he was the lead and um
Osama Blair was in the episode it was
just an episode it was the only it's one
of the few episodes of Television I've
done if not as a but as a guest star
really
and I had the best time we shopped for
like two weeks and I was just in heaven
I got to improvise and have fun I felt
like I was a kid I didn't care about
where the camera was what it was doing
how I looked I just was enjoying life
and you know I made like I remember it
was like 1800 bucks for the episode and
I was like oh my Lord that's amazing
actually rewind that my first gig was I
was on Late Night with Conan O'Brien and
this is when nobody listened to him
nobody Late Night with Conan O'Brien and
the character I was a character who
didn't make the show
but they still showed the character so
it was too it's funny it was the
Amsterdam kids and it was two kids who
were misinformed about Amsterdam's
liberal social policies maybe I'll put
this on air it's and it was just like
hey Conan man I had this long hair down
in my shoulders I'm like he's like yeah
so it's the Amsterdam kids folks and I
go yeah Conan you know man in Amsterdam
you could just squawk down in the middle
of the street and take a dump and no one
will care man it's performance art cone
he's like no no no no that that's not
true no it's true and we I went on and
on and it turned into like six episodes
and it was so heartbroken when they
stopped but you know what kind of always
bothered me
I was a guest on Conan O'Brien and I and
I like Conan
but uh we did a pre-interview you know
the pre-interviews and I said oh I have
a great story because I used to be uh
you know recurring character win the
show when he was just first he goes and
comes back to me goes yeah Conan doesn't
want to talk about that he doesn't like
to talk about that old I go
it's happening I was on it's epic I
never understood it but I was like okay
well let's talk about I guess today's
news
oh my God that's amazing it was fine it
was fine so that when you booked that
what was that for you emotionally and
how did how did you tell your parents
did you tell them I still have the
message
um you know
they I don't remember them going wow
this is great you're playing this you
know character on the show that nobody
watches I don't remember them being but
I remember my friend Kent brennaman left
a message which I still have he goes
Rosenbaum
good Lord son I'm turning on the TV
and I see you on there on this Conan or
whatever
dude give me a call
and I gave him a call I hadn't talked to
him for a while and he was a good buddy
growing up and after after that we just
yeah amazing close friends but I
remember I was like wow he's excited so
it's always fun when your friends are
excited or your friends might watch a
show that you do or because most of the
time they're like most of the time you
do a lot of work that no one that goes
unnoticed sure most people don't have
time like I'm like hey man I'm doing
this everybody wants me nobody watches
do you ask your friends and family to
watch stuff you do no very very seldom
uh you know with music I'll say the
first album I was like Hey guys worked
really hard could everybody do this you
know I sent out like 50 emails to
friends just a thing and yeah but I I
don't really do that a lot right I don't
you know yeah I don't say hey watch this
do this yeah I just kind of like you
know if they know a minute you know you
hope they'd go see it it's interesting I
I feel the same way I mean I I do do
some obviously the Instagram the obliga
you know and but I feel and I'm
wondering if it's if it's more of you
know you don't want to you know burden
people with like having to watch it as
much as it is preserving that fourth
wall
so that when you're performing you're
not thinking about like who's going to
be watching this you're you're in the
moment yeah I think if you think too
much sometimes and like having people on
set always bothered me can't have it and
I and I have had it before like even at
a convention that I was at so one of my
friends
yo hey can me and the famine I hadn't
seen them in so long and they moved and
I I felt like I have to see them right
but you know it was it was it was like
you know I had to it's energy it's a lot
of energy and and when they're on the
set you know it's always like someone's
watching me I can't really focus I'm not
well you're not in it you're not in it
have you done that before and regretted
it oh yeah completely yeah no no no no
one you know no one anymore and now with
coven you can anyway right but even
before that yeah very also you know you
know after a half hour of craft service
and them hanging out there they're bored
out everybody's bored no one cares it's
like no one wants to visit you're doing
this scene for four hours now exactly
right yes are they gonna move on yeah
I'm like I hope so now you know that
it's not that glamorous did you ever
deal with like I mean we're getting into
like you know the career and stuff
because I know you did a lot of TV guest
stars I know you did a lot you soap
opera and you did all these things
um were you always did you were you
excited about the things as they started
happening or was there a time when you
said oh [__] another guest star for this
when am I gonna get or were you always
kind of excited and eager and like
living in the moment you know I mean I
get to do this I always got to do those
guest stars and no listen there was a
time when when you're like no no I I
don't know that I ever fully
fully you know took those opportunities
for granted especially at the time
because I was trying to build you know a
you know a resume and also trying to
with a guest spot usually it was like oh
I haven't played this role before this
this might be interesting so as you know
and at the time it was really the only
way to Cobble together a year it was
like you want a book uh you know guest
spot and that kind of thing I'll tell
you the most impactful guest spot that
turned into probably one of the biggest
opportunities of my life was was lost
you were a guest star last was I'll tell
you quickly how that happened
I my wife was a huge fan of the show I'd
watch the pilot and I was like cool but
I lost the thread so I stopped watching
you know a few episodes in but she was
like a devoted fan and then me too yeah
oh yeah and and uh a year and a half
into it and I like the ending I don't
care what people say thank you for that
I really did you and me both
um so you were along for the emotional
right exactly really emotional at the
end well there you go so so I remember
she said look and she was acting at the
time she goes if either one of us gets a
job on that show we're all going to
Hawaii if it's a guest spot we're all
going that's the rule and I'm like all
right Shannon all right fair enough sure
enough I got the I got an audition this
is uh the beginning of season three and
I'm like oh man and we had to go to a
kids orientation for uh for a preschool
for our oldest son and we're like I I
got to do this this other 13 pages of
material like I'll never know this by
tomorrow
it's not gonna happen and my wife's like
look just don't say no anyway long story
short I looked at them at
and then I woke up in the morning saying
there's no way I'm going in on this
thing and blowing my shot and lost and
it's not and then I read it and I was
like you know what the hell with it I'm
gonna go and I bailed on my kids uh
education
and I was like I'm going in this room
and I didn't know the material all that
I certainly didn't know off book I knew
the essence of it go in there but
usually I wanna I don't know how about
you I like to be off book look I have to
be off book I think you know you know
and the thing is it's I've talked about
this but it's not easy for me to learn
lines as fast as most people but I like
to be off book yes always always but go
ahead so you can relax and you can play
yeah you can truly be there of course I
I mean most actors do not all but most
and so I wasn't obviously and I go in
there and I and then I see guys who are
completely different age you know uh you
know uh erase everything you know types
and we're like wow this is I don't know
what I don't know if they know what they
want necessarily for this role I was
like I'll just do my thing and I went in
there and it was one of those I'm sure
you've had these where you're like I
don't know I don't know what's gonna
happen and it it somehow comes together
in the room doesn't always happen
certainly not for me but I was like I
think that came together I think there
was some connecting and I think it kind
of worked but you never know but sure
enough I get the I get the yes and I'm
like yeah you know and it was almost
like that zest commercial I had that
same sort of reaction it's like we're
going to go to Hawaii my wife's like
where I'll go and I was like okay oh
yeah so we all went for the guest spot
sure you know did this backstory for uh
you know Elizabeth Mitchell's character
and I was like that's it I'll never I'm
not coming I was in a backstory there's
no way and then I get a call five weeks
later they want you back on the island
in present time and that changed
everything so that there was an opera
there was when they said that at that
point I was like what does this mean is
it one episode they said no they just
said they couldn't say and they didn't
know they didn't know and they wouldn't
give you a guarantee of at least three
no nothing it just went I just went and
I was like I'm not gonna question this
we're just gonna we're gonna go with the
flow and I went and then I kept coming
back and coming back and then the role
sort of is This role that was shrouded
in mystery and so I benefited from that
because it was like well who the hell is
this guy this is weird that looks cool
weird looks like he's got eyeliner on uh
you know you hear that a lot because you
have I wish you don't understand you've
got the best eyebrows eyelashes I mean
you're just so like you look at your
like you're striking but for me I have
to have my friend Joe come over and talk
about I look like an albino I swear to
God you darkens my eyebrows all right
when I'm on set they have to do that
they have to you know I'm just kind of
like the Plain Jane here but anyway go
ahead so that becomes something but they
still don't make you a regular it'll
season six and in fact the head of uh
ABC
then they were like no more guest stars
for him or they were like it was it was
like you know you it was during the
writer strike and a lot of [__] was
going on but did you ever think you
could be a regular well it's interesting
how this how this happens you know and
then he told us I don't think I've told
this particular part of of oh good of
how this works out so it they didn't
know to and to be fair to the writers
they they didn't know where the role was
going they sort of went with it they
knew where the show was ending and where
it was beginning it was going to start
on Jack's eye and then and on his eye
and emotionally they knew and and
thematically they knew everything else
was movable parts and which was what was
amazing about the show is that you know
they they it's like what uh what Damon
said is like you know once they you know
they hit the walls they started like
they're boxed in well they started to
climb up the walls and so so they were
so inventive and and the show was so
rich in that way and it was amazing and
my character benefited from that so lo
and behold it gets to a point where you
know it's I love guesting on it I've
been recurring on it now for a season a
bit but I need I need pilot I need to
get a pilot I need pilot money if
they're not going to commit to anything
you know I got to support the family
yeah my wife had just you know uh
essentially quit you know acting so I
was like it's on me now
I got to get at least a pilot fee if not
a pilot that goes to start paying for
these schools and you know you know just
life and so I was like well just you
know and so I did this pilot called or
Kane for CBS
is about a Cuban family of sugar you
know uh in the sugar business in Florida
and uh with Jimmy Smits and Hector
Elizondo Rita Moreno it's a great cast
amazing cast and um but I was like I
hope this doesn't jeopardize my role on
Lost yeah because we asked we said look
I may do this pilot but if you guys
offer us something just even a six
minimum episode thing I won't do the
pilot because I want to preserve this on
lost because you know I mean I love the
role they wouldn't do that and they're
like we just don't know we can't so I
was like well you know I got to pay
bills man I gotta you know yeah and look
the cane was a great opportunity in and
of itself it was like these great casts
so I was like like and but I've got to
also feed the family so so I went I did
Kane I had a blast on Kane and then I go
back and then they call me back on lost
and I was like oh they need me now I
lost and then I I remember Landing in
Hawaii and I remember telling Jack
Bender I go don't kill me off do not
kill me off on the show I don't know
that this Pilot's gonna get picked up so
I please don't kill me off
and he goes what's it about he goes well
it's about this you know wealthy uh
Cuban family and you know that is in the
rum business and you know Florida goes
it's about rich people in Florida
because that's never going to go you
know so yeah just conceptually he's like
that's not gonna get picked up and sure
enough he gets picked up and they don't
kill me off and I'm like oh no no I mean
I'm like now wow I hope I didn't put the
show in a pickle but you know but not
your fault but it's now you know so not
my fault so sure enough you know but now
I was like I hope we're able to work
around you know and I did 13 episodes of
Kane it didn't go beyond that but as I'm
doing that I'm hoping I hope they bring
me back I lost and sure enough Kane you
know Kane gets killed through the rider
strike and then and then lost does call
me back and I and I go great and then at
that point we're like hey can we do a
deal anything you know and they're like
we just don't know where the role is
going and they didn't know they didn't
know so very long story I you know I
continued doing lost and then another
opportunity comes up and it's just a a
six episodes to test for Kath and Kim
you know to you know to play one and
therefore if you force their hand
inadvertently and and that's when they
made the deal those bastards but listen
it's just the way of the business I know
they're trying to save money they don't
want to make your regular it's like you
know and they don't they knew how an
integral you know I mean listen they
they do and they don't uh to be fair I I
don't you know when it's that and
there's a lot of characters that's what
I'm saying he's like yeah I know that's
true and if you get on the other side of
it as a producer you have to think look
it's not an unlimited budget you know
and and these things get inflated very
quickly and it's crazy where they start
cutting and they have to because they
have to justify it so I get the other
side of it you know yeah it's just the
business it's just it's just the nature
of it and until you learn leverage you
you don't know what you know what you
have and it's not uh you know there's no
animosity there it's just it's just
understanding how it works you know yeah
you know you we were talking originally
about
before that store in the other store
which are great stories
but we're talking about like you you
know you didn't mind being guest stars
and that's because you especially have
I mean I don't say lucked out but you
have worked hard improving yourself and
they're like whoa we got to bring this
guy back over and over again it even
happened on Bates Motel right weren't
you a guest star on that well like a
recurring the Bates was different Bates
was you know I'd worked with Carlton Q's
son lost you know he was one of the
exact producers on that show and so he
asked me to come and do Bates but it was
again they didn't have the money to make
me a regular right so it was like look
this will be recurring we'll give you
this is what we can afford first season
if there's Chemistry Between You and
Vera we're thinking Long play there and
then we'll make a regular second season
and so that's what happened so so but
still sort of like that's sort of the
same thing there wasn't if you prove
yourself as an actor and they're like oh
my God we got to get this guy well
you're right but then again you know
Michael you know this more than anyone
is as an actor that you're you're always
kind of auditioning for your job yeah
you know until you somehow become
somewhat indispensable to the storyline
and it's rare that that happened friends
you're you're always kind of auditioning
for that role to stay relevant as a part
of the show and to be ass back season
after season because yeah you have to
get that letter every June uh that where
they pick up your option and and you
have to be integral to that show so I
learned that the hard way on suddenly
Susan um you know or no I didn't I don't
know I learned it that I saw it you know
Brooke Shields right yeah great love
lovely great great group of people all
amazing incredible that was the
beginning
yeah there you go we love you absolutely
Steve Peterman Gary doncic incredible
and I just had lunch with him he did
three years right we did four years four
years yeah and so but I remember uh uh I
don't know if um if you've read for uh
now I'm blanket on his name ahead of
casting of Warner Brothers for the
longest time Tony Sepulveda yes Tony's
public I call him sepuloveda sepulved oh
Tony good old Tony man so Tony cast uh
suddenly Susan amongst many of the NBC
shows who's my Groundlings teacher yes
he was that's right he was a groundless
teacher he's incredible he kept trying
to recruit me to go there I was like no
it's great I heard it oh man I could see
it I loved it I loved it but Tony I
remember at the end of the first season
you said do you realize that every at
least one guest spot was hired was fired
every week at the after the table read
and the first season
and it was and I looked back and I go
he's right
somebody was fired and I won't say what
name some names I've been fired off a
table
um and it's and it's especially in that
world the sitcom world is it's so unless
you're hitting it at the table there's
no job security and you're proving it at
every run-through and you're fighting
for those jokes in every run through and
and it's it's a very much a fear-based
medium we've done a a bit of a half hour
too right four counts yeah exactly you
know my buddy John uh I won't say his
last name I don't think he gives a [__]
but he did a table read for a Will
Ferrell who is Pharaoh's partner Adam
McKay at the time
they had this TV show
and he flew to wherever and he did the
table read and he went to his room
and his agent called him and said hey
man they let you go he's like what
he's like yeah the table read I guess
didn't go well they're looking for
somebody different and he's like so he
had to get on a plane and fly back yeah
yeah it's happening to me do you get
yeah how do you how do you remember
feeling oh awful just completely
ejection rejection oh listen I remember
it happened to me and then I got off the
phone and my son was there and I was
like I just got fired and he's like and
he's amazing he's responsible you'll get
another one and he's like I was like
thank you for that that was so sweet of
him but it's it's one of those things
where you just go
you take the blow you take the hit and
you know obviously you you pick yourself
up and you know day at a time kind of
thing but you can't help but take it
personally there's a million reasons why
there's there's wrong with me what is it
a buyer yeah am I not maybe I'm not the
correct they found me out I'm not a
great actor yeah I'm the Imposter that I
always thought I was it's there's a
million reasons it's [__] it's
because of fear-based and they didn't
come and say hey
um let's talk to you about the role you
know the reading we would cast it for a
reason you could more energy whatever
they just fire you it's so stupid or
arbitrary or there's always been uh a
hang up about hiring in the first place
and they had someone else in mind and
they never got their way and there's so
there's all of these things that are
layered with these decisions yeah that
summer control some of them are out of
your control some are not but some are
out of your control you can't guess
which ones are which you know I hate
table reads they're awful they're awful
because you don't know if you're giving
too much energy they think I'm gonna be
like this in the show or and maybe I'm
like this like oh no he's kind of boring
[__] you
yeah yeah so you know do you find that a
table read is helpful to you as a writer
oh absolutely just to re I've had some
Pilots read that I've written and having
friends come over and read them and
bring them to life absolutely it brings
life to them and I also when I hear them
out loud I go yeah yeah that's not what
I want in my head interesting obviously
but
um yeah I think it does help you as a
writer it helps you you know what you
have on the page sometimes is your own
voice is your is what you're hearing but
what other people when you actually hear
it out loud from other people it can
make you just change directions or go
yeah yeah I need more of that I need
less of that but um that's not the
answer I was looking for because I write
and I I I don't need to hear other
people say oh you know I mean I normally
don't but I have done that no but no
listen I but I know other writers are
like you most of them are like I need to
hear it I was like no no you don't my
writing is I'm a Harvard grad yeah I
studied English I don't need people to
hear and read myself it's Flawless it's
absolutely not the reason it's because I
feel like it's the table reads never
gonna be an accurate representation of
how this is going to play out on its
feet What actors are going to bring to
it you know how they're going to
interpret it it's never going to be that
and you know you can kind of already
hear like I know it doesn't work on the
page when I'm reading it so I know it'll
definitely there's no one who can make
this work yeah you know that's just the
way I feel it I understand let me ask
you this real quick because there's a
couple more things I want to talk to you
about
um and then we get some rapid fire
questions but I mean there's so much I
want to talk to you I want to talk to
you about we're going to definitely talk
about your your wife's book and it's
great it looks amazing you've already
told me you'll fill me in all is not
lost Shannon Kenny how I friended
failure on the island and found a way
home if this doesn't make you like our
listeners I mean go ahead go ahead and
listen I can't gush about my wife you
brought this and you're like I think it
makes sense for your show and I'm like
please I didn't want to do a Shameless
plug but I thought having having
listened to your show and thinking this
this might be right up your alley this
is about my wife gave up her career to
be a full-time mom when her second son
was born she was pregnant with uh with
Marco as she was working on Seventh
Heaven you know she was on that and when
soon as she was born she was like I just
can't do it I go I not that women
shouldn't be able to do both she goes I
know myself I can't not be home and give
this child both of them what they you
know all of me and she's like you know
if it's cool with you it's on you to
just be the full-time actor and I was
like are you sure you want to give that
up because this is a woman who had no
money when she came here got into
Juilliard couldn't afford to go to
Juilliard I was able to win a
scholarship at Cal Arts did every job
you can imagine scrubbing toilets
anything just to pay for you know the
living expenses to be able to go to that
school and then she this is all she ever
wanted to do and and she paid for the
first year of actually from from a
working as a soap opera in Australia her
first year of of college and then
subsequently won that scholarship so
this is a woman who sacrificed
everything to for this career and then
she gives it all up after a 20-year
career in film and TV and theater to do
this and then she's like after the kids
are somewhat self-sufficient she's like
finds his cavity in her body is thinking
like oh my God this creative spirit that
I had nurtured for years what do I do
with this it's like this giant hole and
I know I should be grateful for these
kids but by the same token I'm like I'm
just there's a death inside spark is
yeah is gone and I I you know so it
brought this incredible spiral and this
all came to a head while I was while we
all moved to Hawaii and and uh I was for
me to do loss they all we put the kids
in school there and it was all all kind
of coming to us she sort of Crash landed
on the island kind of like the plane did
and it was her whole experience that
year that book is all about that and it
so if you're ever going through you know
a moment where you are completely lost
as she was in in terms of your identity
she identified herself so much as this
actress and and You've Lost That
identity and you're no longer that and
you've lost this dream and you've come
short of your dream in the way that you
envisioned it you had to give it up for
something else that this book is uh you
know I think will really speak wow
that's
amazing I mean just the the thought of
you know sometimes even like on another
level it's like maybe you've um that
thing that you've always wanted to do
and that was what you're most you're
part a big part of you
is gone but maybe you have a different
path or maybe you have a different
whatever or you're trying to get that
spark back or there's all these
different things and thoughts and on the
back of the book The the personal
Memoirs I guess
I mean look look at this you say Vera
from eager right yeah
um Shannon's touching chucklesome and
shoot from the ovaries testimony reminds
me that those obligatory ruts in life be
it bereavement heartbreak or stuckness
or things that are happening for me not
to me
for me not to me how do we unleash the
energy to move ahead of our creative
dead ends how do we overcome the Unseen
forces that stand in the way of
inspiration
read this gorgeous narrative you just
may give yourself the confidence and
permission to move past your feeling of
being stuck beautifully I think that
speaks for itself holy [__] it's
incredible and and and and she's she's
right on every level and and it's also
she's right it's a chucklesome in the
sense that uh the there's a lot of humor
in it and Shannon you know even though
she's going through all this pain uh is
not uh she's a very funny person and
yeah and so she finds the humor even and
and the irony in a lot of these
situations but it's yeah beautifully
written by all is not lost how I
friended failure on the island and found
a way home get this book Shannon Kenny
oh thank you buddy I mean I'm this is
just apropos oh thank you um thank you
for this I want it autographed um also
uh I have to ask you what's it like
kissing Vera from ego
all right I'm gonna plead the fifth
there come on you can't answer that can
you I can't no she's a lovely listen
she's a very good friend you're a very
professional no I always talk about
Kristen crew kissing her on the small
balls like it was amazing great breath
listen it's
you don't have to answer no she's a
listen she's a very good friend of mine
and she is I I have always loved her I
think she's brilliant since I saw her in
The Departed she's incredible I was like
this is an actress I will always watch
she's extraordinary she really truly is
and even you know we did five years
together we worked five years and and
there was never a moment where I I
wasn't just like completely shocked or
impressed by her insane range you know
and her man you know one of the here's
what one thing you always pick up things
from the from actors that you admire and
one of the things I picked up from her
because she had so much material she had
these huge speeches and monologues and
stuff in the middle of these scenes
beautifully written by Carrie Aaron and
but she would get these and she's like
dealing with kids you know at home and
this and that and they're young and
trying to memorize this stuff for three
in the morning and you know you know
crying the kid's crying and she would
get there and you know and she would
flub and it's interesting that when you
watch actors flub and they go up on a
line how they react and usually I I know
I'd I'd heard that you were an athlete
or you did Sports growing up yeah hockey
and everything yeah you know and there's
just to me I've wrestled and I've you
know I've played soccer and it wasn't
that particularly good but I uh you know
I loved sports but I if I mess up I try
to muscle through it I was like you know
and I
tend to tighten up a little bit I would
see her flub and I'd do the and that's
here do the opposite and she would just
kind of do this thing where she goes aha
and she would turn into jello and I was
like what is she doing and then I was
like oh my god of course you know you
can't relax you can't remember anything
when you're tight how could you possibly
feel anything when you're tight other
than tightness you're not going to be
open to anything and it's certainly not
going to help your memory to suddenly
beat yourself up because you forgot the
line
and I was like I was like I'm stealing
that for sure I'm stealing that is
awesome it is and it's like interesting
what you learn from different talents
that you admire and that was certainly
one thing I was like oh my God I'm
taking that off well we didn't we didn't
even get into this but it's like you
know I I didn't know you directed a lot
you direct a lot you create your own
stuff you like you're doing it you're
not just an actor for hire you're like a
triple threat no I don't know about that
you are you I mean I mean I'm trying you
know and you know Michael it's like
anything look you had this incredibly
successful podcast you're doing things
outside literally successful no
incredibly sad incredibly so and you
know you too Ryan both of you guys have
this incredible podcast and so no you as
you know we all know but you kick around
along in this in this business so you
have to create opportunities for
yourself you can't simply wait for that
phone to ring no and I was lucky enough
that Carlton couston carrier and they
open the door for me to direct on Bates
Motel so they open that opened up you
drink like three five or something I did
three of them and it was an
extraordinary experience I I mean that
was the biggest one of the biggest gifts
I've ever been here you know that opened
up a whole new world so I'm actually now
going to I think next week I go to New
York to direct Law and Order which is
kind of Full Circle because that was the
first thing I guessed it on on Prime
Time 31 years ago wow so now I'm so
blessed to be able to It's amazing And
you you did the good doctor you worked
again what you directed an episode with
the couple episodes uh Freddie Highmore
Freddie Highmore he's awesome he's
amazing who's in Bates Motel who then
the good doctor you went and directed
that which probably had to be special
because you know them and you probably
got the best out of them and he loved
working with you he probably said yes
bring him yeah I'd worked with the the
writer uh you know with David Shore
before another show obviously with
Freddy
and Daniel Day Kim produces on that show
and I worked with him a lot so I happen
to know three different people you know
so that that was a that's another
another gift and yeah I've been lucky
enough to to you know do a few other
shows a New Amsterdam I most recently I
did three episodes on that show was are
you do you feel like you're sort of
gravitating towards more directing and
you're not as much acting or you'll just
want to do whatever no I think I'm open
to to whatever and I think you know I
mean I don't know how you feel about
this whenever I'm doing one genre I'm as
soon as I finish that I'm aching to do
something completely different do you
feel that way no no I don't uh I usually
uh do something and then go
let's take a little break let's relax
okay no I don't mean like you have to
jump right away but in terms of
creatively do you feel like my mind now
I think I was I was dealing with a lot
of anxiety and depression stuff for like
the last year or so and I wasn't in the
great greatest place I just didn't feel
like me and now it's starting to come
around in fact someone said last night I
started going on about I got this
project with my my buddy that
um these guys want to do and then I got
this other thing and then I'm I wrote
this one and I started talking she goes
do you hear yourself right now and I go
what she goes this is three months ago
this is not the person that I was
talking to this was like uh
I just want to move away well let me ask
you something because I know this speaks
to so many people particularly with a
pandemic the shutdown I think just in
general how did you come out of it like
what did you use to come out of it
you know
It's a combination of things I think
it's you know it's therapy it's exercise
it's the right you know meds yeah for
not for all people but like you know
sometimes it helps I notice a difference
with me
um but also a good group of friends that
are here for you okay they've been there
they've seen it that you know remember I
had an anxiety attack at my birthday
dinner are you there uh no I don't think
so I invited you didn't I I think we're
out of town oh thank God
that would have been awkward but I
remember her going ham having an anxiety
attack I think I should go and they're
like I just don't don't go we're aware
of it it's okay and I'm like
and I'm just like you know I feel like I
was gonna pass it was just a really
rotten time and I was just on the wrong
meds and getting in the right meds and
it just was like I just wasn't me and
for the last couple years I just felt
like
I'm just drifting away from who I am and
exactly your wife's book you know all is
not lost which I'm going to read um
and with a combination of all those
things that I I spoke of I feel like I
have um I'm putting it all back together
and yet there's sort of this
there's less pressure on myself now and
more excitement knowing that I have the
choice which we always do most the time
if you're lucky
to do what you want to do and you don't
have try to do something you enjoy try
to try to add an element of fun in it
um so I think it's a combination and
it's like you know and so that's what
I'm going through now but yeah yeah I
know you told me about your back
problems which I'm sure has precluded
you from doing certain kinds of but you
say you did you did some exercise right
yeah look I play ice hockey on Monday
nights I play tennis yes on Tuesday
non-contact hockey though now I guess
but still a very physical game yeah but
we don't hit each other on purpose
um but my thought is I could either have
back pain and not play hockey and tennis
and do these things and be in a little
more pain than that or I could you know
just say screw it I'm gonna you just
from my mind and for my body and the
feeling of just disappearing for an hour
or two while you're playing sports I
don't like hiking I don't like doing
things like lifting weights I like
competitive sports right football
baseball hockey
um tennis golf even golf golf's a little
slow for me I like a little but um I
like the competition I like the
adrenaline I like the you know I'm like
okay this is exciting this is a game
there's two teams we have to win I have
to get some hits I have to catch a ball
I have to that is what I really love and
that keeps my mind a little sharper than
it normally would no question and it
it's scientific from what I've I've
learned through I had my therapist who
basically said that if you get if you
get your heart rate up to 135 beats per
minute for 25 to 30 minutes four times a
week it's the equivalent of taking an
antidepressant for 24 hours
wow yeah I don't do that well you
essentially do when you're playing
hockey you get hockey yeah in tennis
you're getting your heart rate up for at
least 30 minutes over 135 beats per
minute maybe not continuously but over
the course of it probably can believe
you will have right yields amazing I
noticed now I box now I bet not like
sparring but I trained you know if I
don't do it I I feel the down but if I
do do it I feel an endorphin rush that
does last me 24 hours it's extraordinary
and I think I don't know if you saw the
Jonah Hill documentary yeah okay I I
I've got to finish it I've lost half of
it but 85 percent is it's that's uh
stats starts the
psychiatrists like a therapist yeah yeah
he says 85 of your therapy is is uh is
working out is physical
and and it's not so it's it's it's it's
extraordinary what that I think that's
true but I also think there's a big
component in therapy in working your
[__] out with something yeah yeah
there's no question but yeah I think
exercise in therapy those two with
exercise you're you you know you're you
have the ability to yeah exactly in
terms of getting yourself off of that uh
or having a baseline there to work with
certainly exercise is is as valuable you
know it's in some cases as an
antidepressant it can be yeah it can be
all right this is [__] talking with
Nestor carbonel oh no say your name
again in Spanish
[Music]
Mexican but my dad never learned Spanish
just growing up did you learn it in
school no I took Latin and I didn't
remember that either very very useful
yes
from The Exorcist when she speaks a lot
you know I remember I went to uh Cabo or
something I got the plane this guy
recognized me years ago he's like Mr
luto or my Mr Rose mum give me a call
and I'll take care of you
it's pretty cool man yeah I still have a
message he called me I don't know why I
gave him my number and he goes hey Mr
Luther
hey I need I want to give you a deal
I want to make a deal with the Luther Mr
Luther would go to uh we'll go swimming
we'll do all these things with your
group come on give me a call
that's pretty cool [__] talking with Mr
carbonell
these are from my top tier patrons the
the patrons patreon saves the podcast
it's folks like you patron.com
inside of you here we go rapid fire you
gotta answer relatively fast Kelly yes
you're simply Charming I love your work
lost Bates the morning show we didn't
even get into the morning show the
weatherman they're my favorites how did
you prepare for the role as Alex Romero
in Bates Motel and really get into that
character that's so sweet of her uh how
did I prepare for Alex Romero
um I remember I remember coming to the
set you know you know in theater you put
on the shoes first when you get the
first day of rehearsal you know you
should start with the shoes because you
get into the thing I remember I came in
with a mustache I had grown a mustache
because I was like this guy's got a
stash for sure and and I was like you
know I had this like massive thing that
I was really happy about I landed in
Vancouver and Carlton Q is there and
he's like hey man I like the stash but
uh I think we're gonna lose it and I was
like oh no there's that's like my
theater shoes so I was like but at least
the stash gave me a grounding to start
with like this is a guy who makes no
bones about who he is even you know it
doesn't care so it started with a stash
do you grow up you grow a good one
though yeah yeah back then it was not
bad it was a bad I want to see it you
got to email me one yeah I actually have
yeah do you have one right now you know
how you like you have a picture
ten minutes for me to go
I love your performance on psych because
the experience as wonderful as it looked
I love James I love do lay Maggie he was
on the podcast Maggie Lawson amazing uh
such a blast working on that show I mean
it's so much as you know improvising did
you do the show no we never asked
amazing that's okay I'm sorry little
Lisa do you have any behind the scenes
stories you could tell or share when
filming Dark Knight with Christopher
Nolan oh my God Dark Knight yes I do a
quick one all right so I uh I have to do
a speech on Dark Knight that it's not
scripted on the page you know it's just
like yeah the mayor says a few words
this and that and I'm thinking oh so you
know what I'll just write something you
know and because I'll give the speech
and then the Joker's supposed to kill me
or try to kill me and I'm like I better
write something so I wrote something
here I am writing Chris Nolan's group
and so I get to I'd done a scene the day
before I get to the hotels in Chicago
and uh all of a sudden there's a speech
waiting for me me there and I'm going
they're giving me the speech now and
it's like this long speech and I go I
had this idea of what I was going to say
I was like why was I thinking that that
was ever going to go but now I was like
now I got a mess I can memorize that
yeah and it was like 10 o'clock at night
I was like were you stressed yeah were
you nervous of course anxiety yeah it's
massive and it's like there's gonna be
1200 extras how did you do it awfully so
I I was up all night learning it finally
I I remember being there with 1200 you
know extra background workers there in
the middle of the financial district of
Chicago I'm supposed to give this speech
you know and he's using an IMAX camera
which is like 200 Grand a take is what
I'm thinking like these things are
massive and so expensive and uh and sure
enough I'm doing this after walking this
parade with uh with Maggie Gyllenhaal
and you know and then and so I I go to
Maggie it's like Maggie can you just
look at this I don't even know her I was
like I should see if I'm off book here
so I'm like running lines with Maggie as
we're walking and finally I get to the
podium and I Gotta Give the speech and I
don't want to read off
would do he'd kind of read things and go
hey or or usually they have those
prompters where you you know you know
they would cut away yeah you know but I
was like yeah but no but I didn't want
it so I wanted it I wanted it to be so
sure enough I'm like going off and then
like on the first take like I kind of go
up and then all of a sudden
going up and there's 1200 people and
then there's Chris Nolan there's got a
iPad that he's suing it seeing it on an
iPad not far off the set and then I'm
like oh sorry sorry can we go again he's
like and he goes nesters it's just me
it's just me and I go Chris it's exactly
it's just you it's Christmas oh my God
but it was in that moment he really
truly relaxed me and I was like this guy
is like amazing so you know he was like
all of a sudden I was like dude you're
super cool and uh and that was that that
was pretty it was cool for Maggie to
read with you yeah how cool is that uh
Raj
where were you when you found out you
were First cast on loss and how did you
react well we already know that you
already answered that question yeah yeah
but I'll tell you when I've got the Dark
Knight where I was somewhere I was in
the jungles and in the jungle in Hawaii
shooting lost and my phone rings as my
manager oh actually this is interesting
and he goes uh I had read for Chris
Nolan four months ago and I was like
whatever it obviously didn't happen and
so I'm in I'm there with Michael Emerson
you know in the middle of the Jungle in
between takes and I'm going why did I
pick I picked it up my manager's like
hey so Chris Nolan wants to um wants to
know uh if he can see some tape on you
and I go for what movie he goes the
Batman when he goes that was like four
months ago and and I go yeah because I
just send him this reel over this stuff
I go no
I just done Smoking Aces and they had
come out and it was like Matthew Fox it
happened to me I ended up killing
Matthew Fox which was another weird
coincidence and then I'm going now see
if you can get Joe Carnahan to send him
those scenes because that's the most
recent stuff and it's Universal I don't
know
Carnahan was such a mensch my manager
calls Joe Carnahan they sent over uh you
know a splice together performance 15
minutes of my work to to Chris Nolan I
get a call back you know days later in
Hawaii dude you're doing The Dark Knight
I mean you know so those are those
moments that you're like you know those
are the those are the highs for sure
geez
have there been any characters you
played what was particularly hard to
connect with them
with a character many many where you're
like wow this is like my foot doesn't
fit in the shoe you know and and uh
usually sometimes those are offers where
you're like I didn't read for this
and they got me and and uh and that is
the Beauty and the curse of an offer
he's like I I always say that you know
you just you you're like I didn't read
for it so I hope they're cool with this
interpretation of this character yeah
there have been somewhere that it
doesn't it's not organic and you gotta
make it work and then eventually you you
hope you do and uh yeah but there have
been there have been more than a few for
sure this has been awesome I love that
honestly you're just as I thought it
would be it's just just so easy I told
him I know this is gonna be like such a
I go I wish I was this laid back or no
but you're so honest and humble too it's
like you're telling your story and like
you know between you and Michael as are
you Ryan here's the thing dude I mean
look we get the privilege of being this
incredible business we get the privilege
to tell stories for a living I mean
that's an incredible to help people and
yeah and and you and you hope that if
you can get give somebody respite from
their day and so if they've had a bad
day you do if you happen to inspire them
in some way fantastic but you have to we
have to that perspective we're not
curing cancer here yeah you know I mean
not that nothing not that those are it's
a binary choice but I'm just saying you
know you know we're part of We're
cogging the wheel that tells a story and
if you don't if you lose perspective of
that oh good luck to you man
Amen on that uh what's your handle so
people could follow you oh on Instagram
I'm I'm at Nestor carbonell and then on
Twitter uh at carbonyl Nester at
carbonyl Nester from the people who you
know on the back of this book that
you're you're uh your wife you guys are
friends with these people and people
just people I mean people like working
with you they like you as a person they
like your wife you're just genuine
people I think that people want to work
with other good people they want life to
be as easy as they can well thank you
and I I know people feel that way about
you and I appreciate that I know they do
um I've heard that from so many people I
know I know that to be true
um thank you buddy I think you know I
think uh being being grateful for what
we get to do I think I think I think it
helps you know I think it helps in terms
of keeping perspective like we were
talking about before you know and then
and just staying grounded man I mean you
know yeah you know and having your
friends around you to keep you grounded
question we as you spoke to before that
I I would love to speak to all my lows
because I've had plenty of them you know
you you you kind of I feel like someone
said it really was like I want to
operate in a 7 out of ten I don't want
to get too high and I don't want to get
too low if I got a seven I can deal with
the ups and downs a bit better and I
think it's finding that seven and not
getting too worked up about those highs
to to worked up about the lows and give
you some sanity are your parents still
with you yeah thankfully yes yeah how
old are they so my dad just turned 87 on
the fifth and then my mom is uh
76. and they're in New York they're in
yeah in Connecticut in Connecticut you
still talk to them a lot are they proud
of you they're sweet yes they're very
sweet yeah I mean you know they're like
my mom's like my agent you know my dad
too I love it super sweet man but I I
wish I wanted to get more into you as
well and into the maybe next time I
would like if I hope there is maybe next
time I love you hey thank you thank you
guys that was awesome thank you buddy
thank you Ryan
[Music]
dude you guys got everything yeah he's
got talent he's got looks he's a
sweetheart he was a great guest on the
podcast married to an author married to
an author
you've really done it buddy all right
top tier patrons uh you're gonna help me
out with this sure let's do it you need
to read off of it for the first time
ever I'm not going to be good with uh
why don't you read them see if I can
come up with Nancy D Leo no no no you
want to just D okay Leah s Kristen
uh oh wait I'll always see what you're
doing
Leah asks Kristin k
little Lisa you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico
P Robert
B
Jason
W Sophie
M Raj C Joshua
D Jennifer
I want to say NRL
Stacy
Stacy's Mom's got it going on it was one
of the first one of the two letters you
just said
Stacy L Jamal M no no Jamal Jamal F yep
Janelle B Mike
e oh there's a lot of these
you just read them now fell down Supremo
are you yeah is that right that was
right yeah it was correct all about
Supremo what's the next one
uh
um wait we gotta give me the first name
99 more 99 more Santa Santiago M Chad
Chad W Leanne
Leanne P Maddie s Belinda
B
n
and Dave ho Dave hole
Sheila G Brad
t
Brad G
right now Brad
l no
what is it D Brad D Brad D bratty
yeah all right we should go now all
right let's keep going uh so well
give me a couple more all right uh Ray
Tabitha T Tom
Talia M yep Betsy D angel
B the angel
p
Angel m
Rhiannon
see
Corey okay
Dev Maxim Michelle
okay nope
Michelle
a yeah all right well I did all right
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D yavor Joey
M Eugene and Leah Corey Jake Busey
Angela F Mel s Christine s Eric H Shane
R Andrew M Tim L Amanda R Jen B Kevin e
Stephanie K Jarrell Jim and Jay Lee and
Jay Luna R Mike F Stone
henge H
Brian L Kendall L Meredith I Kara C
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P Esteban G
Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F Marion Louise
lyfus
Bell that's how I'll remember that Mary
and Louise Dreyfus license Romeo B
Romeo's bleeding Veronica Q Frank B
gentine Nikki L April R Cassie B Derek
Anne thank you guys for all your love
and your support and patreon.com inside
of you
um I'm Michael Rosenbaum I am Ryan
Taylor from the Hollywood Hills in
California all right all right give it a
wave thanks thanks so much for uh
listening today guys I hope you enjoyed
the podcast uh be good to yourself
foreign